so yesterday i was in boston teaching uh
so that was why this morning i was
actually in my hotel room frantically
trying to recover my slides because my
video card seems to have died and so
every time i plug my laptop into an
external projector the entire laptop
crashes so i was transferring it onto my
ipad and hoping this works so i
apologize
that was not supposed to be the problem
of all the problems out here this was
not the one that was supposed to happen
um so um if this all like completely
falls apart during the talk and nothing
is on this thing i'll turn into a
blackboard talk and hope for the best um
but you know let me just reorganize this
okay so this is a good start so today
i'm going to talk about
kind of i'm gonna follow up on what
david said which is that he was talking
about general methods for
using these uh sums of squares
relaxations to
get stronger algorithmic results and
today i'm going to talk about in a
specific context which is uh finding
so as you can see this is off to a great
start okay so i'm gonna work on trying
to
recover hidden sparsity through sums of
squares relaxations
and okay what's the high level picture
the high level picture is that i'm gonna
be talking sort of about two major goals
and they're gonna
kind of be both related and that related
the first goal is the algorithmic end
result which is finding denser sparse
objects so all the rage these days is
sort of a general class of problems of
the form
i give you some limited noisy
information find something sparse right
so i have some sparse hidden object kind
of buried in a bunch of noise um somehow
you have to find the object that's there
and there's a couple a couple
algorithms that match this template i'll
talk about them in a second
um but you know the main question is
just when can you do this obviously if
sparse
is
too weak if sparse means missing one
coordinate or something you'll just
never find it in any kind of case it
might not even be information
theoretically possible
um on the flip side you know so the real
question i guess is how sparse does the
interesting thing you're looking for has
to be
and how nicely unsparse do the ambient
uninteresting things have to be okay so
there's a whole bunch of questions that
fit that mold which i'll talk about on
the next couple slides
and
many of the results that are out there
and i'm going to have to on the intro
slides make some over generalizations
that are
over generalization so bear with me on
it it's just to give the high level
picture but the high level picture is
that a lot of the algorithms for solving
the find something sparse type problems
are some form or another of l1
minimization you say you know sparse
things have a good l1 norm compared to
not sparse things minimize l1 hope
something good happens and a pretty
broad set of cases the answer is yes
something does
so
uh but however the how well does this
work like how much sparser does the
sparse thing have to do
in essentially all the applications
where it's an l1 minimization thing that
i know of there's an answer of the forum
one over root n that i guess we've seen
i think you saw while i was teaching
yesterday in boston and it will come up
a little bit later in the conference
and that one over root n is kind of an
intrinsic feeling one right it's
basically just
i look at l2 norms and l1 norms and i
ask when can i sort of
identi when does the difference between
l2 and l1 really pull out the sparse
thing it's when something is a lot
sparser where the a lot is some ratio of
sparsity of one over root n
okay so this one over root n you'll see
occurring fairly frequently
and
the main question we're going to ask is
can you ever do better or is this really
there
um
okay the second question
um is can we prove guarantees for the
sum of squares or lesser hierarchy when
the number of levels is small and this
one there are some results but
surprisingly few you know um
roughly speaking these hierarchies
empirically and kind of from an
intuitive standpoint seem very strong
and david gave some explanations of why
they seem very strong in sort of a
complexity setting but broadly speaking
you know they seem like they really
should do much better if i sort of
replace level two with level four
um but there's really very few positive
results for a number of levels that's
less than some poly and n you know so
there's a bunch of positive results at
square root of n levels or n levels or
maybe slightly lower but if i wanted to
get something at say 12 levels or log n
levels there's mainly negative results
in the literature and i guess the short
version of that is that it's kind of
hard to do algebraic geometry or
semi-algebraic geometry if you're only
allowed to look at low degree
polynomials you know even if you're
asking low degree questions often you
have to sort of rely on cancellations
that happen at a much higher degree
and so
the sort of second goal that we're going
to shoot for in today's talk in some
very special cases is just to get
non-trivial provable guarantees for the
loser hierarchy when the number of
levels is some very small number not
root n not n but four or eight or log n
okay so those are our two goals and as
you may have guessed we're going to
combine the two goals and so the
goal for today's talk is going to talk
about a couple cases really focusing on
one where the second goal lets you solve
the first so what i'm going to do is use
loser hierarchy to solve some sparsity
type questions and in doing so
outperform what seems like the intrinsic
limit one over root n that you're stuck
with at l1
um okay and
again i'm going to sort of what i want
to do is first very quickly just kind of
run through the scope of what these
results look like and then i'm going to
pick one of them and actually do it with
equations so i'm going to sort of do
sort of the fluffy high level these are
all the problems one could think of that
match my template and then i'm actually
going to do one and kind of just
illustrate in detail
roughly how this technique works
so okay the first problem which is the
one i won't do in detail of the two main
problems is uh dictionary learning and
sparks which is also known as sparse
coding and this one has come up a lot
lately and you know the high level
picture of the question is i give you a
bunch of vectors a1 3im and rn
and i give you samples from some
distribution so you get examples of the
form the sum of w sub i a so a to the i
the i vector where
um
you tend to get sparse combinations so
each of the w i's is from some
distribution where most of the time it's
zero so the probability that an
individual one of them is uh non-zero is
something much less than one
um and our goal is from this to recover
the dictionary so the idea is that i'm
giving you a bunch of
samples from some distribution i promise
you that it's sparse
in some basis and you want to find the
basis in which it's sparse
um
so
this is a very well studied question it
sort of came up in machine learning back
in the 90s to find the right
representation of observed data so the
moral picture here was i give you
you know that sparsities illustrates you
sort of looking in the right
representation of something i give you a
bunch of numbers and i want to say what
is the representation that illustrates
their structure um i lifted from boaz
this convenient pretty picture um and
this has a lot of work because it's been
and it's been used a lot in machine
learning vision and neuroscience and the
rigorous results that were out there
there were under various combinations of
assumptions a bunch of them but largely
um
and again this is the slide over
generalization there was a simultaneous
paper that is under slightly stronger
conditions in some parameters and not
others etc but largely speaking the
existing rigorous results were one over
root n for the sparsity the mu which was
the probability
that one of the w's was non-zero so this
is what the one of the one over root n's
i've been talking about and this says
that if i gave you these random samples
the distribution they're from it should
be that the vectors that are proposed to
be sparse are actually really sparse
they're sparse in the sense that uh all
but a one over root n fraction of the
entries are zero for these sparse
vectors and then somehow hopefully that
means that the signal really jumps out
at you
um okay so
um
what we can show and it's going to be
using techniques that are related to
what the second problem i'll talk about
but somewhat different enter in a
different paper is we'll show actually
that
under
um so in all of these cases once you you
need some assumptions right like so for
example if i were to tell you that
um you had so much noise or so
sort of minimal sparsity that you just
kind of get sparse vectors anyway just
by chance then it's really hard to find
things like you don't want to say fully
independent samples from a general
distribution
right like if you did if these samples
were sort of if the w's were completely
independent you'd have some
probabilistic guarantees you could
exploit you want to minimalize minimize
the
assumptions that you have but you do
need some that roughly say
that the stuff that isn't supposed to be
sparse like the uh you know that an
arbitrary vector doesn't look too
strongly like your sparse vectors that
you're finding so you need some mild
assumptions uh that are really there
from the identifiability standpoint and
under those even in sort of
non-independent coordinate cases with
over complete bases so
here note the ais could be a basis or
they could be much more than a basis and
in applications it's very easy to
motivate that you'd want to have many
more dictionary vectors than you have
dimensions and even in those cases
um we show under some mild assumptions
that you can actually recover yeah
in the real world how how sparse
do you want to be able to handle like
you're actually doing vision with this
um i mean i think that okay so there's a
couple real world apologies i was gonna
make shortly um in the real world the
house farce is as sparse as you can the
apology i was gonna make is that right
now the algorithms that we have for this
problem the running times are not quite
in the real world world yet
um they're you know end to a fairly
large number
um but you know so this but in the real
world part of it um
i mean really whatever you can find
right like
i think it's used in very different
applications so it's kind of also the
sparsity level varies pretty widely no
but one answer is that the real world
algorithm they use this gradient descent
on the non-convex function
it stops working
yeah so i mean like somehow the um the
limitation is an intrinsic one to the
heuristics even
and so
the one over root n is a limit of what
you what the algorithm would try to do
and so you're not going to use it in the
real so it's what they use it for in the
real world is where their algorithm
never works um
i guess one uh quibble though is that
there it's also if you make enough
independent decisions like ica right yes
and there there's no right there that's
that was my uh sort of brushed under the
rug even when non-independent under weak
assumptions so that was what i was
referring to when i said that you can if
you
assume that everything is sufficiently
independent then you can kind of
probabilistically understand exactly
what's going to happen and pull out the
answer which is what ica lets you do
but here sort of the win in this and
also in a paper that you guys wrote was
that you can do this under
very weak under much weaker assumptions
on how the how independent the
coordinates are so i think independence
is really a stretch right like i don't
i don't i think independence is a pretty
strong assumption to hope for no but
people claim that for ica for wise
independence is
um let me answer that offline just
because i'm uh
i don't want to get too hung up on this
slide so let me answer that either
afterwards or offline just to kind of
push forward but
um i would
slightly dispute at least that strong an
assertion but um anyway let me come back
to that at the end just because i want
to
kind of i don't want to dwell on my
intro and not get to the technical part
but i'm happy to answer questions about
that
okay so
this is the first one uh the second one
which is one that i'll actually work out
in detail is what we'll call planted
sparse recovery um and
the it's a fairly similar one
intuitively but with different
parameters numbers and goals and so the
idea is just i give you some random
subspace and here for now let's actually
go with very this is non-trivial even
when the random really means random so
for today's talk we're going to not
worry about we're going to make random
as nice as we can and just make it
really legitimately a uniformly random
subspace from the heart measure
and the goal is i'm going to take one of
these random subspaces which will pick
in regimes where you tend not to have
sparse vectors just by chance and then
we'll just plant a sparse one in it
and so the setup is um i plant a sparse
vector into a random subspace and you
want to recover it
um okay so let me just say that a little
more precisely so the setup because this
is what i'm actually going to do with
math so the setup is i give you an
arbitrary basis of some dimensional
subspace
a d-dimensional subspace of r n and so
think of it as i have the span of some v
prime
with
some fixed vector f zero
where v prime is a d dimensional
subspace
and it's random
and
um we're gonna think of this as the span
of iid gaussians
and then we'll say that f0 is our
planted sparse factor so it's some
arbitrary sparse vector
um and mu will be the sparsity so by the
mu sparse vector what i'll mean is just
that if i say mu sparse i'll just mean
that the size of the support is mu times
the total number of coordinates so mu
equals one over root n is the sort of
what is the thing i was referring to on
the previous slide and kind of now we're
talking hopefully better than that um
okay and so the goal is going to be to
find a vector
that quote recovers the planted sparse
vector okay so let me just briefly
mention
what the goal i'm going to solve is and
whether or not you really need such a
strong goal is a
moral question but we can get it so we
might as well prove the strong result so
for today's talk i want you to think
about the goal as exact recovery so the
goal is going to be that
like really this is an actually spar
sector planted into a random subspace
there at least information theoretically
should only be one and so we're going to
try to really recover it we're not going
to get a close vector we're going to get
the vector where the approximate really
just means sort of to high numerical
precision
um and so think of it as you want
running time that's log one over epsilon
doesn't matter how the non-zero
coordinates in f-zero are selected
not for this now
um
so right yeah um
so f zero is arbitrary it's just that v
is nice um or v prime rather it's nice
um okay and so
uh note that f zero is not required to
be random
and um in fact you can even actually
randomly choose v first v prime first
and then adaptively and adversarially
choose it
so that's going to be our problem and it
shows up as a primitive in a bunch of
cases before i talk about how to do that
i just want to mention briefly a couple
other problems
um the other problems that sort of are
solvable by related techniques to what
we're talking about that i'm not going
to really go into and i put briefly as
my excuse for just
i want to mention they exist but i don't
really want to define them technically
because some of them require fair
digression to do so
but the problems were these same
techniques actually let you break some
existing barrier
one of them is noisy tensor
decomposition so broadly speaking i give
you some tensor and i want to
find an approximate decomposition of it
into a bunch of rank one tensors
assuming that such a thing exists and so
the idea is that we're going to be given
a tensor that is close to it but in a
fairly weak sense of close so the
problem is just i you i give you noisy
access to a tensor that's proposed to
have some
non-trivially low rank representation
and i give you sort of noisy answers so
it's close in the spectral norm which
means is like considered by a matrix as
if you consider the tensor as a matrix
basically or as a function on the sphere
and you can think of what this lets you
do that you couldn't do with the sort of
existing l1 motivated techniques is it
lets you
handle a much greater level of noise at
the expense of a fair amount more
computation so rather than giving a
practical fast algorithm that solves it
where you have inverse polynomial noise
so you're basically just solving the
exact fairly close to exact example of
your tensor we're going to solve it with
either constant noise or very close to
constant noise depending whether you
want a polynomial or quasi-polynomial
algorithm
and um
and actually
the result will be that under very mild
restrictions uh that just are necessary
to make the problem make sense we can
actually do this even when there's a
huge amount of noise when the noise is
constant instead of inverse polynomial
and kind of the relevant interesting
fact about that is that this is a regime
where you no longer get like where if
you do these local gradient heuristic
procedures
um this is enough noise the one over
poly noise is what you need so that
actually you expect the local minima of
the nearby thing that you're minimizing
has something to do with the local
minima of the original thing and this is
outside of that regime so the
interesting fact here is that this is
something where the local minima has
nothing to do with each other
um okay so the next one i want to
mention which ties into what david
talked about was sparse vectors in
arbitrary subspaces and this one is i'd
say a substantially technical harder
result than what i'm talking about today
which is why i'm not talking about it
today but i
find it kind of surprising and so the
setup was previously i told you
i'll give you a
random super nice subspace find a sparse
vector in it and we can do that under
very good you know very very weak
assumptions on the sparse vector but
very strong assumptions on the
randomness right so sparse can mean
pretty dense but random means super nice
subspace here we're going to solve a
appropriately formulated variant for a
worst case subspace but with a weaker
guarantee and so the assertion is and
this actually has false expansion
implications
which are not enough to well david
co-authored the paper so therefore it
was didn't refute anything david said um
so
but it's something where they're
stronger than they are non-trivial
implications and the so the setup is you
have to be a little careful how to
formulate it but roughly the question
that this lets us answer is i give you a
d-dimensional subspace that either
contains or almost contains depending on
your choice either way a um the
characteristic function of a
of a sparse vector and we're going to
require we're going to recover a vector
that is
not as sparse but non-trivially sparse
and so
um ignore the word analytics varsity for
a second let's just pretend i wrote
sparsity what this says is that if you
have sparsity mu in an arbitrary
adversarial subspace you can find a
vector with sparsity mu times d to the
one-third
um even root d is not super trivial um
uh it's not super hard but it's uh the
okay so what is analytics varsity
analytics it's actually also i mean
um
i mean still let's np hard to determine
whether points are in general positioner
right right somebody a very strong
statement about you know i can find a
vector which is
you know k sparse but not k minus one
sparse if it
right exists right
um
yes they'll both be analytically
sponsored yeah so let me let me define
analytics sparse but yeah yeah um so
analytically sparse is a relaxed there's
one probably if i took a somewhat nice
arbitrary subspace it may have no
exactly sparse vectors in it so if i
were to find you know any kind of exact
sparsity guarantee i might be asking you
to just find the vector right like i
could just give you but you somehow you
want something a little bit more
geometric and so analytics varsity just
says that if you look at
norms of the vector you look at the
ratio of you know the p norm to the q
norm for some
of your for your favorite p and q then
in our case let's say four and two then
the ratio behaves as if the vector were
whatever that sparsity is
so think of it as you know if i give you
a spark if i
give you a vector that wasn't exactly
sparse but was had a very high dot
product with a sparse vector that's more
of the kind of thing one would hope to
find and if you don't have that sort of
assumption i think you are quickly
lapsing into the np hard question range
just because there might just be exactly
one sparse vector that's even vaguely
sparse so the um yep this is i think the
right way to formulate a relaxed version
of this problem where the answer isn't
obviously np hard
and then the question that we're solving
here is for an arbitrary subspace with a
sparse vector in it we're going to find
a fairly sparse vector
okay um so now let me um oh also i wrote
this one i did really didn't want to try
to explain this one because aaron's
going to do a much better job at it
later
so i'm just going to say also some
problems in quantum information with
related techniques and push that forward
to aaron later in the week
okay so that was the high level picture
of what we can do and broadly speaking
the upshot was
things that have sparser or noisier
answers than you would expect from just
doing l1 minimization
um okay so let me now uh
tell you the quick uh i'm going to say
recall from previous talk and remind you
what david said in the last five minutes
because that's the main tool and then
i'm going to run through the algorithm
uh for the uh what's on for the planted
sparse sector thing in the random
subspace
i think it illustrates a couple nice
features okay so let me remind you what
david told you right at the end of last
talk about the high level picture for
the sare hierarchy and i'm going to do
this fairly quickly because i think
everybody well a lot of the people here
could do it at least as well as i could
um
but if i do it too quickly do stop me
because i'm you know since david just
said it this morning i'm going to breeze
through this but possibly at a
unsustainably fast rate if so you know
stop me and ask questions um okay so
the basic goal that one addresses with
these polynomial hierarchies is some
polynomial optimization problem so think
of it as i give you some program p
that's going to be maximize some
polynomial p of x
over think of p as being a low degree
polynomial where this is if all those
p's are low degree this is still np hard
and think of the goal as i want to
maximize p of x subject to a bunch of
polynomial constraints
x
the maximization question isn't the
domain oh so you could impose that with
the ps
so for example if you want it on the
hypercube you just like you know say
that
x x of i squared equals one you know so
x y squared minus one equals zero so the
reason i wrote it this way is that you
could all sometimes you might want the
sphere for example so it's nicer to keep
things general
um usually most of the cases i know of
this will either be constraints that
will put you on the sphere of the cube
um
but not always okay so
the idea that so david yeah what about
inequality constraints
i kept him out because it will not show
up in anything i'm going to do today the
laser hierarchy does
say things but inequality constraints
i'm
not using them and thus didn't want the
additional notation um
so today i'm really going to think of it
as
equality but there is there are ways to
write things that are just slightly more
technical that will deal with
inequalities and i'm trying to dodge
that point just to not deal with it
um okay so
this is our goal and the relaxation says
it so as david said you've got sort of a
relaxation and you're gonna have a
primal and a duel and maybe i'll put
them both up just so you can see them
and
uh sort of let me start with the dual
the idea that was that the dual
is i want to convince you of a bound on
this polynomial so i want to convince
you that there is no pos you know no
possible
uh point uh subject to your constraints
so that this polynomial is
uh bigger than something than some cut
off and so the idea is that i do that by
producing a proof and the proof system
that david was talking about the one
i'll use which is that i give you a sum
of squares proof so that means that i
give you a bunch of polynomials and
basically i'm working with the assertion
that if i give you real numbers if i
square them they become positive and so
if i want to prove that p is less than v
what i'll do is i'll basically say if i
add um if i prove that
if i add something that's supposed to be
zero then i'm adding zero uh to the
objective function if i add something
supposed to be positive i'm only making
it bigger so if i can prove that my
objective function times something
that's positive
um you know is and so if i take
objective function minus some guess
multiply it by something strictly
positive
and then
show that that thing is positive then
i've got a proof of a bound right so
you know just all this is doing is
taking the axioms that something is the
square of something is positive and
zero is zero and then seeing what you
can deduce from that only using
polynomials of whatever degree you're
looking at and then the dual thing that
david talked about was the pseudo
expectation idea and so the idea is that
the right dual object to the sum of
squares proofs
meaning that if you were to take the
actual search for sum of squares proofs
it turns out to be a semi-definite
program and if you write down its dual
the objects that come up are sort of
things that are pretending to be
probability distributions
and what that means is
uh is that actually what they give you
is the alleged expected values of
polynomials up to some degree d
so the primal objects that we'll deal
with say i'm going to try to solve this
program p
which is i want to maximize a polynomial
over some set
and then what we're going to do is think
about it as
you know there might be many solutions
so the right question if i'm doing
anything convex isn't one solution it's
a distribute any convex combination of
solutions so we're going to think of the
goal as being to try to describe any
probability distribution over optimal
solutions which of course we can't do so
instead what we're going to do is
describe numbers that look like they
could be the moments of that probability
distribution and so the notation i'll
use
uh following david is that i'll write an
e tilde just to mean um sort of a propos
what this semi-definite program proposes
the answer should be and so the set up
here is that a pseudo expectation which
is a primal solution to this relaxation
is a linear operator on polynomials of
degree less than or equal to d
that satisfies the constraints that uh
moments should satisfy and so what are
those constraints one of them is that
the expected value of one is one
the other is linearity of expectation
and the last one is that the expected
value of the square of anything is
supposed to be non-negative
so
um it turns out that you can write down
if you wrote everything down carefully
these are the constraints that
characterize primal solutions to the
lesser hierarchy
so the picture that we're supposed to
have here is that i give you this
optimization problem we're going to try
to we're then going to solve what turns
out to be a
low degree semi-definite program so if i
give you the degree d relaxation there's
like n to the o of d monomials
and so any what you end up with is a
semi-definite program of size n to the o
of d which you can solve and end to the
o of d time
and so the
what you get out of your what you get
out of your relaxation is you get a
bunch of numbers on the primal that
propose to be the expected values of
polynomials
so they proposes to give you a linear
math that computes expectations and it's
subject to the sort of easily
enforceable constraints that these
numbers should obey
and then the dual objects are proof that
those distributions can't exist
and what that means is a sum of squares
proof
and the hope here is that somehow given
these we're going to be able to so this
gives us a way of taking any program and
relaxing it and then the question is
just does this relaxation accomplish
anything
meaning does this you know can we say
anything about how good an answer this
relaxation gives compared to the actual
answer to the original program
um are there any questions i did that
sort of where the pi's come in the
primal
oh uh that's a very good point um they
should have expected square zero
so they should have ex so the expected
um
did i drop that oh okay so
um that is a fair i guess i this was a
generic pseudo expectation right so the
constraint that p i equals zero what
that shows up as thank you it shows up
as the expected value of p times
anything is zero
so e of p of x is zero e of p of x times
you know seven x cubed minus four x
squared over two is zero right any
polynomial times zero is supposed to
have expected value zero
some other questions
okay so now let me kind of uh remind you
the picture and then after this i will
stop reminding you and actually start
doing theorems and
the last reminder i want to give you is
the picture that david was describing so
the picture is the following our
approach here is going to try to take
this sort of
moral description of moments and proofs
and use it to actually guide our
rounding algorithm so the idea is that
you know pseudoexpectation is supposed
to look like the expected value of
polynomials
and um
you know if i actually
were and it turns out we can actually
solve the problem of finding pseudo
expectations they just might not can
actually
correspond to legitimate expected values
and so
um
what we're going to try to do is uh lift
our proofs about real random variables
to proofs about pseudo expectations
and so kind of the high level picture of
what our goal of how all these
algorithms are going to work is as
follows we're basically first going to
say okay you know what pretend that i
gave you something you completely can't
compute which is pretend i actually said
i'm going to take all the actual optimal
solutions to your problem
and give you a probability distribution
over them so i'm going to give you a
probability distribution distributed
over optimal solutions so if you could
just find one of them you'd be
completely done because it's uh finding
hay in a haystack
and the idea is that i'm not going to
give you the distribution as an oracle
that samples from it because that would
be the whole problem instead what i'm
going to do is i'm just going to give
you the moments of the distribution and
what we're going to try to do is we're
going to try to say if i gave you an
actual distribution
and i just gave you its first d moments
how could you recover a fairly good
solution to the original problem
um and then what we're going to do is
we're going to say here's how you do it
for an actual probability distribution
here's how you prove that it works and
then we're going to take the proof that
this
thing that worked for exact actual
legitimate probability distributions
worked and we're gonna figure out if we
can actually write that proof
only using low degree polynomials um and
so if so if we can show that uh now that
i could take sort of an actual solution
and then write the proof of correctness
only using moments of low degree
polynomials then that will actually give
us a way that will actually
depending on how strongly we state this
either formally or morally suggest how
to find an actual rounding algorithm
right so the idea is we're going to
think so that's the kind of intuitive
picture we're going to work with
um
and rest of today i'm going to give a
work example of this approach
for
planted sparse vectors which i did
because i think it's a nice clean one
it's probably the technically easiest of
the bunch which is
why i picked it and it also illustrates
a couple key points
that i think are worth noting and i'm
going to mention them before i talk
about them so that they kind of stick
out when i talk about them but there's a
certain set of frequently occurring
facts or pieces that seem to show up in
a lot of these applications that i just
want to mention one was as david said
these these things sort of all seem to
hinge upon the question what can we
prove with low degree proofs right so in
all of these cases
really we're going to be looking at
the setup we're going to look at is just
could i convince you there was no good
solution only using low degree
um
the next thing that i want to point out
is that we have to use the problem
structure and this is a very strongly
true statement that's kind of important
which is that if i were to only think of
these optimization problems that we're
solving as optimizing a degree d
polynomial over the cube or a semi
algebraic set or whatever i want all of
these things would need polynomial
degree and provably so so um later i
think there will be some talks about
giving under very general settings how
to get strong convergence results at
like degrees that are poly and n and
those are
necessary if you're doing arbitrary
optimization
so somehow what we have to do is design
an algorithm that exploits problem
structure to
just say that we don't need to just
treat this as general polynomials uh
next thing is that our rounding is
directly motivated by our moment
intuition you'll see a concentration
measure tends to come up a lot um and so
do multiple norms
uh and i guess i kind of want to give
you the what i think are the two
motivating questions for any algorithm
that looks like this
and i claim that these two things are at
least necessary if you're going to solve
any kind of optimization problem
one of them is suppose i actually just
gave you the moments of a whole bunch of
solutions
how could you isolate one of them or one
fairly good solution i guess uh if i get
if you have any algorithm that solves
the problem clearly it could solve this
problem by ignoring the information
you're given so this seems weaker right
i'm giving you
access to additional information which
is just
a bunch of actual moments of actual
solutions how can you pull one out and
kind of the other one which i think is
maybe more technically motivational is
the
um if i actually gave you if i lied to
you and i just gave you a planted say a
planted sparse vector problem where
there was no vector
how would you figure out that i'm lying
um and we'll see that in some sense
these two questions will motivate the
structure of the algorithms so how would
you tell if i just didn't plan a vector
at all
so
very briefly the previous let me
remind you sort of what kind of the l1
algorithms look like and then i'll
motivate how we don't do them so the
idea is that the they were motivated by
l1 minimization and so just um
the idea here is that we're trying to
find i give you a random subspace in a
very sparse sector and we're going to
look at what properties are sort of true
of typical vectors and what properties
are true of our sparse vector and hope
to find one that lets us separate the
two
and i this is a sort of caricatured
picture of a typical vector
um you know it's coordinates put you
know put theta or theta tildes around
everything i write here of course it's
just to give you kind of the broad scale
a typical unit vector um and i should
say by the way throughout today i'm
going to be using expected value norms
so think of it as it's a normalization
that makes this very convenient so for
example the way i wrote it here
um i'm going to write that the one norm
of this is one think of it as the
expected value of whatever polynomial
you're looking at if you pick a random
coordinate
uh is that's the scaling i'll use so a
tip and so this is a unit vector uh
not um that over root n
and so a typical unit vector uh you know
all of its coordinates are roughly the
same size it's one norm is one it's
infinity norm is one it's ratio of one
to infinity norms is one
um whereas for a very sparse vector it
kind of looks like this right it's got a
bunch of coordinates the sort of least
sparse sparse vector is going to be that
they're all kind of the same size so you
have a bunch of chords
the expected value of uh negative one
squared or one squared over
um it's just a nice normalization later
um
okay so now a typical sparse vector the
point is just that now you're going to
really see a difference between the one
and infinity norms right if i were to
take a typical sparse vector then it's
one norm you'll be adding a bunch of one
over root muse and you'll get something
like root mu whereas its biggest
coordinate is one over root mu and so
instead of getting a ratio of one you'll
get a ratio of mu
which is much smaller and so the this
says that there's this says that if you
do the right minimization problem you
can hope to find the sparse vector right
so what it says is that we're going to
try to find our sparse vector by
computing the best ratio of f1 to f
infinity
um and that may not be obviously a
problem you can solve but it actually
turned out to be an lp and a very easy
one
because the idea is that what you'll do
is
uh note that this is the same problem
i'll minimize the one norm where i'll
constrain
i'll guess which is the biggest
coordinate so for each of the possible
largest coordinates i'll solve the
problem
of minimizing the one norm and then
whichever one of those will be the one
that comes from the one to infinity norm
and so what you get is that you can
solve this nice lp and you can end up
with the vector that actually does
exactly minimize the one versus infinity
norm and then the question is how well
this works
so
there's my annotation note that i
believe was earlier in the slide when it
was on my laptop but that was my
expectation norm thing that i just said
um okay and so now the hope the idea is
we're gonna try to find f0 by computing
this and if you look at how sparse f
zero has to be our caricatured vectors
actually kind of tell us the answer
right like
um
you know we need to be able to the one
over root uh d where d is the dimension
down here just comes from this exact
assertion right like we just need to
know that
when i
actually look at the sort of typical
versus sparse
okay so
now i need to tell you one more thing
which is why you might say this seems
like it works for all mu and now we have
to have to ask the question essentially
how bad a solution do we expect to be in
a random subspace so the previous papers
um
let me sort of in a second i'll tell you
exactly what the answer is um okay so
the previous papers showed that what you
can do with this approach is actually
get a tilde of one over root d
and i claim that this is actually tight
and i think they also claimed that it
was tight um and so
the first question i want to ask before
i say can we do better algorithmically
is are they just analyzing it wrong um
and
the
this is when i said that i think there's
an intrinsic reason why these things
can't do better this is the intrinsic
reason is that it's not just that the
analysis is wrong and so you actually
expect a random subspace
when you have any mu that's worse than
one over root d you actually expect a
random subspace to have a vector
that um
you expect that no longer will your
planted vector be the solution to the
problem
there is a theorem that for every
subspace of dimension indeed there is uh
that's true actually yeah
um
right so actually boss makes a good
point it's not a random subspace it's a
random subspace is your best case
scenario actually it's all sub spaces
um
and
in particular a random one and um likely
i guess i mean probability very likely
um
okay good so the proof i'm giving will
show likely the real proof will give
exactly um but this one's simple to draw
caricature of and also i might have
forgotten this late last night um so
um okay so
my assertion is that a random subspace
is in fact likely to have some vector
where the ratio is of one over root d in
which case you really won't find the app
the correct answer right disagree
it's true right um but this one's got a
nice pretty picture which is why i did
it i just wanted to give the argument
for it i come up as a good counter
example to a lot of things and i've told
enough grad students this argument that
i feel like i should put it on a slide
um and so let me convince you of why
random subspaces tend
in fact with very very high probability
to have vectors with this bad ratio oh
actually no the one to infinity i'm not
sure i buy this anymore the two and
i think you're telling the truth for uh
two versus
i guess we should work it out i thought
it's true for every subspace but i guess
we should uh
may or may not be telling you the truth
but this one is definitely true
um
okay so
um okay so anyway the um the idea is
we're gonna think of our subspace as a
span of a bunch of random vectors
right and then i'm just going to
construct for you a vector that has a
very big uh you know very bad ratio of
norms and so the idea is i want to
construct a vector in a random subspace
where some coordinate is much bigger
than all the others and it turns out
there's a very and again the reason i
write this is that actually i've had
multiple times in my
life where people have suggested
conjectures where this breaks them so
it's just a good example to know of and
so how do you get it so the idea is that
i'm actually going to by hand construct
it and so what i'll do is i get my
random subspace as a span of a bunch of
gaussians independent
gaussians and what i'll do is i'll just
add them up but i'm going to add them up
with a carefully chosen sign
so that i get uh some coordinate to be
really big okay and there's what's the
dumbest way to do this i'm going to make
the first coordinate really big and the
way i'll make the first coordinate
really big is i'll just make all the
signs so that uh the first coordinate is
positive
right and that will be a vector in my
subspace so i'm just going to take each
of the vectors that i get as my random
things that span the space and i'll
either add it or subtract it so that the
first coordinates add up and all the
other coordinates cancel right so what
you get is vectors that look like a
bunch of plus minus ones the first
coordinates are all plus ones all the
others are plus or minus ones and so
your first coordinate tends to be
about root d times all the other
coordinates
and so what you end up with here is just
in a random subspace you actually expect
to have a vector where the first chord
is root d times all the others
and
that is the the construction that shows
that we actually have something tight so
here we have something with a one versus
infinity norm that's about one over root
d
okay so now let me tell you what we'll
do to do better
if my oh there we go uh
my
ipad is struggling with my slides so
okay we're going to today focus on the
case where d is o of root n so remember
there's two parameters here there's the
dimension of the subspace and there's
like there's this sparsity here we're
going to look at lower dimensional
subspaces but much denser sparsity and
the o of one over root n is mainly to
keep things clean we can soften this a
little bit
okay so the main theorem i'm going to
prove for the remainder of the time i
have is that
you actually can find this planted
sparse vector even when mu is a constant
so
that means in a root un-dimensional
subspace even if uh you know a tenth of
the coordinates or non-zero
um that's you can as opposed to one over
root n you can actually find it um and
the idea is just we're going to look at
better norms so instead of comparing two
to four sorry instead of comparing one
to infinity we're going to compare two
to four what can you say about d is
linear
uh less it's a harder problem for
various reasons um
so here the algorithm that i'm giving
really
so there is a result that will say that
essentially as if you want to say almost
linear
then what you can do is get an algorithm
that will have you want to say almost
linear instead of being linear it's
linear it's n to the 1 minus epsilon and
i believe that what i'm talking about
although i should check it will give a
slower algorithm for end improvement for
n to the one minus epsilon where the the
running time will blow up as that blow
up pretty badly with epsilon this one
works up gives a non-trivial improvement
up to like n to the two thirds not sure
about it like i'm definitely we
definitely can improve
until these end to the two thirds of the
two-thirds this algorithm works but if
you use like the two to the two plus
epsilon norm
we haven't checked that so that's a
assertion i should not be making on
videotape um i i would guess that so
this this algorithm gives better results
up to end to the two thirds dimensions i
strongly suspect um but have not checked
that if you want to down to the seven
eighths that you could do it with using
instead of the two to four norm the two
to the two point one norm
you know but that it so but that would
come at the expense of having to do much
higher degree proofs so you get a
running time an interesting thing to
prove that'd be and sorry let me phrase
that as a as a suggestion for an open
question um so that i am not lying too
badly in video but let me suggest that
the way you might want to analyze it is
by looking at the two to two plus
epsilon norm writing that as a
polynomial relaxing it to a higher
degree let's say relaxation and then
kind of running through this proof
for
um
at an end to the two-thirds because
there's an existing argument for that
breakdown another one huh
one more time
like you need some certificate some so
certificate that a random subspace
doesn't contain this first factor right
so i'm going to give that right here so
after the true to fourth how do you do
that at the end of the two thirds
doesn't that break that that argument
breaks down another one half right um so
the argument i'm about to give here is
going to actually run up 10 to the two
thirds with a trade-off of in the
sparsity so
you get constant sparsity at n to the
one-half and you get better than one
over root n at n to the two thirds
um and
then what i was guessing
slash proposing as a research problem
was that you can get better if you make
more aggressive norm ratios that you can
still do this um okay so
um the first point is just imagining
that we had magical computational powers
and could actually answer certain
questions that aren't hard let me first
just convince you that we'd be we'd at
least not get fooled by the things that
trick l1 versus l infinity so my claim
was these vectors i constructed these
sort of uh adding with positive signs
type things are at least up to constants
sort of the right thing to check for
random subspaces for most questions
about norms
right like if you want to ask what is
the worst case ratio of norms and i
don't care about small factors
these are pretty close to the right
answer and so let's just check whether
they break
um what happens with them and this is
where you'll see the bounds kick in this
is where my assertions about root n show
up is that if you now look at the two
versus four norms of these vectors
you'll see they're not fooled by these
bad examples so a typical unit vector we
have one one one for the two to four
norm because it's all ones here you'll
see that the two norm
now is one and the four norm is like mu
to the negative a quarter
um if you write it out and so what
you'll see is that you know because
you're just looking at you're just
looking at different ratios of norms and
the point is now this sort of uh a
typical mu sparse vector here you get a
n to the one quarter and so now if i
were to look at these bad constructed
vectors what will happen is that we'll
get a vector with this first coordinate
being substantially bigger than the
others but if i'm raising it just to the
fourth power and not looking at infinity
uh norm then it's not gonna get big
enough to beat all the others
um in the four norm right and so what
we'll see is that these vectors actually
have two to four norm that's still
constant as opposed to the mu to one
quarter that you get from a mu sparse
vector
so the sort of motivating uh
mathematical fact that makes this go is
that the vectors that actually show that
this l one versus infinity norm thing
were tight
they actually are not a problem if i
could optimize the two to four norm that
these bad vectors that broke our
previous algorithm they really
legitimately don't break
they're not a good example of um there
being a bad ratio of two versus four
norms right so the two to four norm
minimization that i'm about to propose
will at least detect these vectors as
not being
problematic um okay so
yeah uh so i we i saw i'm cheating i saw
a talk by uh my
story and aaron's and i'm stealing aaron
sidford's exam
even if you take two of the coordinates
and make them set them to be large
like in some trivia way instead of going
all the way to four norm
it's not easy to add up vectors to make
two of the coordinates have large
infinity norms
right so
well that also breaks the countertop i'm
just saying maybe that's a trivia it did
another way
yeah so um
i don't know how to well i mean that
that's a harder one to then break all
examples with right like this one is a
nice polynomial because i guess the nice
thing about it is that two versus four
norm
um i could you can break individual
counter examples
uh a large infinity norm is still a
linear program right right
uh
but how much how large would you make it
i mean you'd still get you'd have to do
a larger and larger linear program to
make some fewer and few like you can
but
because you'll use like half of your
basis vectors you will get two you would
use the best the first coordinates in
the second half of the base the second
base
devices coordinate and you wouldn't win
too much because uh so i right so you
get is this
is really well i think is that what you
get is that you can i thought two was
proposed to be a proverbial too not an
exact two so in sort of in the general
sense of constantly many what you get is
that as the number grows
um
oh good oh that was all you wanted okay
cool thanks um but anyway more generally
you could it actually isn't numerically
interesting that what you could do is
you could try to make a bunch of them
small and what roughly you do is the
same argument just did but replace with
projection onto a random subspace and so
you'll get their their maxes probably
will fall off linear square root wise
with the size of the number of
coordinates
maybe linearly so uh that would be a
harder one asymptotically break whatever
root n until you go to
be a very big yeah which would be a
bigger linear program
um
yeah but then and then right and then
you'd have to just have um you'd have to
have very large linear programs right
like this is going to be a poly a very
small this is going to be an end to the
fourth size program as opposed to an end
to the something bigger than a constant
um
okay so now let's try to let's see how
to turn this into a general algorithm
and the
problem other than the hourglass that's
appearing on my screen um is okay so
more generally let's suppose we could
solve a problem that we cannot solve
because it's n be hard uh the problem
we're going to not solve but hope to
solve is uh maximizing the four norms
subject to being on the unit ball so
really we're trying to get the best
ratio of two versus four
and um let's let uh suppose the support
of f is contained in
some set s of size mu n so let's just
look at what happens with the norms and
i'm going to convince you that something
if we could solve this problem we could
at least in that case recover what we're
looking for
so again this is an np-hard problem um
but if we just kind of do
simple algebra with the
with norms what do we get i'm going to
do this a little quickly because i'm
running a little slow but what we get is
we just get that
um so if we remember we're not using
fake expectations or anything here we're
doing a legitimate actual probability
and we can use the fact you know we can
use uh
the fact that the expected value of f to
the fourth is at least the squared
square
the expected value of the square r
squared and then kind of playing with
inequalities as you go through this what
do you end up with you end up with that
the four norm to the fourth is at least
mu times the two norm to the fourth just
by using kochi shorts
and so what you end up with that says
oh maybe my new
yeah one over here
oh i'm sorry yeah right so mu squared
and a mu yeah so
thanks right so the only the only typo
was this last equality right and uh that
was right good one over me or else that
would have been
very surprising for our algorithm um
right
so
um okay so the so note that for d root n
um you know then what you can show is
that you like what this will give you is
that actually the four norm is less than
a constant times the two norm and that
is true with or without the one over um
so
that says that um so this actually is
why we're hoping for something good if i
could solve this np hard problem
then of minimizing two to four norm i
could at least figure out whether
there's a planted vector
um now uh for bigger d by this is the
trade-off that i mentioned about getting
two thirds or something
for bigger d if i just write the same
computation
um i get
wow okay this is fun um okay so my
um what i end up with this is the end to
the two thirds that i promised if i can
maybe
yeah if i can get back to it if i get
back to anything on my slides okay so
um in a second my slides will
recalibrate but the point was is that
what they were showing was that that was
just a trade-off that you get at the end
of the day so um
that the
okay so there uh if we could solve this
np-hard problem we would get we'd be
able to recover at least determine
whether it was a planted vector with a
constant and
um what are the problems really the
problem or just um
you know we can't actually solve np-hard
problems and it only gives a large inner
product but not exactly the right answer
answer it just gives a thing that's
broad like got a big inner product
and so
the basic picture here is that we're
going to now give an algorithm with two
stages one of them is going to use the
laser sum of squares hierarchy to get an
approximate solution and then the second
one will use an lp to recover the exact
solution from any solution that's
reasonably correlated to it
and
um
okay so i'm going to focus on the the
approximate solution and so what was the
idea the idea is that i'm going to write
out a proof
of how i would do it for actual
legitimate expectations and then note
that my proof works at degree 4.
so
here's the lemma that this all kind of
revolves around the assertion is
that suppose i give you a linear
subspace
with any kind of with with the promise
that nothing in it has a four to two
norm bigger than some constant c
um then um and then i also give you a
planted vector that has a big four norm
uh then and i give you some probability
distribution over the span of the two
that has a big four norm then the
assertion is that
the expected inner product of anything
sampled from this distribution with my
planted vector is pretty big where
pretty big is a ratio of its four norm
versus the worst case in the other
subspace
so why is this true um well okay this is
going to be true
sort of easily um in fact
let me now throw in one more fact and it
will work for hierarchies too so let me
now what we're basically going to use
for our whole proof is we're going to
say don't just assume that our subspace
legitimately doesn't have a vector with
that 2 to four norm ratio but suppose
that it has this fact and it's true with
a degree four sum of squares proof
meaning suppose i give you any subspace
where i can actually
write a proof of that inequality at
whatever let's say degree four although
it doesn't really matter uh okay so in
that case my assertion
is that you can actually translate this
whole statement through to hold for
pseudo expectations right so
um the lemma will be true for real
probability distributions and then if i
can prove the first the assumption with
low degree then i can prove the
conclusion with only slightly worse
degree
and
so then this tells us that the actual
way to solve the whole problem is to get
solve a degree eight relaxation of
maximizing the four norm subject to the
two norm and then um
uh what we'll do is we'll prove the
limit for actual distributions then
translate the proof to low degree
so
um
the last and then the last part which is
probably the harder part is just getting
a low degree proof
of the fact that the two to four norm
ratio of a random subspace is bounded so
let me um
only about five minutes left so i'm
gonna run through this pretty quickly
uh the
um the proof of dilemma for actual
distributions is super easy basically
you write any vector in the span of
these two things as a part as your your
planted vector plus some other junk
that's in the original random subspace
and then you just use
standard norm inequalities
and get that it can't have a big dot
product right like this is just a bunch
of holder inequality and kochie schwartz
applications
um and
something is
continuing to go wrong with myself with
my
um
sorry this is what uh
oh there we go whole proof um okay so
the um
the proof for pseudo expectations is
basically to write exactly the proof i
just did but knew it do it sort of only
using polynomials and if you look at the
proof sort of the main steps first of
all i wrote things with fourth roots in
them so i have to undo those and then
the other thing is that i have to
somehow use i used kosher schwartz and
holder's inequality and kind of the main
point here was that you actually can
write low degree proofs of kosher
schwartz and holder's inequality so the
idea is we're building up this proof
system of what we can certify at low
degree and these are two facts that any
distribution consistent with a
um with a four norm bound if if that
holds then you can actually just check
using positive semi-definiteness you
know you can just check that actually it
will obey kosher shorts and holder so
okay so that was the translation to a
degree to a low degree proof part of it
was we just write the proof of suit
expectations and then note that all the
lemons we used actually hold under these
weaker assumptions so this is your
rounding right uh right this was our
rounding algorithm actually so our
rounding algorithm is now that actually
is a whole rounding algorithm other than
the fact that i have not proven
low degree proofs of the two to four of
the ratio for random subspaces right so
what the rounding algorithm is is that
i've just proven that not only does it
hold for the fact that this so
the fact that this held for real
expectations
was easy and the fact that it held for
pseudo expectations is actually only a
little harder it was just kind of
carefully writing out the proof with
polynomials and then that says actually
that the answer to our sdp the optimal
solution was a pseudo expectation that
actually
obeyed these properties and thus that
guaranteed that we actually could pull
out a good solution so now for random
subspace you need something like uh
eigenvalues of random matrices yeah it's
actually a little even that well morally
yes
um
you need it yeah so i mean let me give
you one side
part doesn't need to be proven right
that sort of can be that's right
yeah so the idea is you need to know
that that the random matrix factor is
true you don't need to
um that you can prove eigenvalue bounds
at degree two right like so a little bit
more this is the part that always
confuses me why don't you need a proof
for that yeah so let me put the proof
sketch up for that and then i'll point
at it to answer it
the degree for sum of squares proof for
this fact
about the subspace i think his question
was why don't you need to so uh
yeah it should be clear in a sec but the
the short answer is just if i gave you a
matrix that i want to certify abound on
its biggest eigenvalue then i can just
um that i can do it degree 2 by adding
the square of something to it to make
things today
but it's a subtle point that kind of is
uh well okay so let me just very quickly
tell you that proof is probably the last
thing i'll get to
um is what is the degree four proof
so what's left over from this was that
we have to give a low degree proof that
a random subspace actually doesn't have
a sparse vector in it and this is kind
of the algorithm that crux here i think
because you know the rest of it was
pushing around expectations and it was a
nice intuition about how to use
pseudoexpectations here though the point
is is that this is the fact that we're
really exploiting that is a strong fact
about random subspaces it says if i give
you a random subspace it has no vectors
with a very bad ratio of four to two
um and
the way we're going to do it is we're
going to
show the following we're going to show
that the projection operator pi on to v
prime so that's the linear projection
that um of f to the four we're going to
show that it equals the two norm squared
minus the sum of squares
right so we're going to give so remember
this is sort of the quantifier that
cindy was asking about was we are it's
not that we have to write the proof that
a random sub like the proof that it's
going to involve random matrices we
don't have to write the proof that a
random matrix has bad eigen has small
eigenvalues we don't have to write that
proof at low degree we have to
say given a specific random matrix that
we can certify a bound at low degree i
see so the match that you can assume
without proof is like that because you
are in this
yeah
so you think about eigenvalues
right actually so the we don't have to
be able to con so i guess what am i
saying is we have to be able to
construct the proof using low degree
functions of the input we just need
there to be a low degree proof
is you know if you were using i don't
know some theorem of algebra you would
need to prove it yeah but just
eigenvalues are special because it's
yeah somehow well they're they're
special
they're special in their squares they're
special and that that an eigenvalue is
the answer to an sdp that's what i mean
um i mean like
i mean if you were to use some other
math here you can use it
like to prove this
whatever you could use whatever you want
i mean nobody has to be wrong
instead of being a random subspace would
be a subspace that comes out from number
theory yes it could be a very very deep
crm yes
that
there is a degree for sos proof of this
thing but it uses you know all kind of
crazy must er
um no so let me let me put the proof up
and then i'll point out what it is but
roughly the let me just say what what i
was what i think they were saying was is
okay so the end of the days i'm given an
actual input subspace
and it was generated randomly
but i don't have to know that it was
generated randomly i just give you the
subspace like i'll give you a basis and
what i have to be able to do is prove
for you using any techniques i want
that there exists a low degree
certificate of this bound for the
subspace
um so i can use anything i want to prove
the existence of the certificate but the
certificate has to be simple
and the certificate that is simple is
something of this form right it's a
polynomial equality that says i can
write one polynomial as another plus a
sum of squares
um and so the
the numbers in that certificate like the
sos is a polynomial the coefficients
that polynomial don't have to be low
degree functions of the subspace
or anything nice like that it just has
to be that there exists
a certificate and i can you know um so
that the certificate is low degree
um and so
um so that's
i guess in the eigenvalue picture the
same thing could be said right it goes
without saying you know regardless of
what deep number theory you use to prove
eigenvalues
you can compute them yes but but no you
can't note the eigenvalues are not a low
degree polynomial of a matrix right like
that's a very good example right if i
gave you maybe okay so let me finish the
slide so anyway the um the upshot is
essentially you're showing that for iid
gaussians um you can prove this
inequality if i then gave you the so let
me just kind of write out what this says
it says that if i gave you the rows of
matrix a these are the polynomials that
we have
um and if we sort of start writing
things out with tensors just to write
out what the actual assertion is what do
we get we get this n squared by n
squared matrix corresponding to a degree
four polynomial and we just have to
convince ourselves that
um so i'm gonna
brush through the algebra to get to the
point the point was is that if we
actually manipulate this a bit what
we're really trying to show
is that
the polynomial we're looking at it's
going to be a sum of rank 1 matrices
which are coming as each of these a sub
i's each of the rows of the matrix
are so each row of a becomes an n
squared length vector that sort of if
you were to vectorize this is a a
transpose and then you're summing up
rank one matrices from those the rank
one matrices generated by each of those
so it's a bunch of and a bunch of rank
one n squared by n squared matrices
and so now what we're gonna do is we
would actually we're going to use matrix
concentration to bound the spectral
properties of sums of random rank 1
matrices
um and
uh
maybe so let me get to the last part of
it which was that if you um sorry i'm
having real technical difficulties the
upshot was that if you just were to
bound the eigenvalues of this matrix
of the matrix that you write down it
actually wouldn't be enough um the
eigenvalues themselves actually aren't
that small but it turns out that you can
add we have this ideal of constraints
that any polynomial that the polynomials
are looking at have to obey and so
polynomials on the sphere have l2 norm 1
and if you sort of add stuff where if
you use that constraint you can kind of
manipulate the matrix into one that then
does have a good eigenvalue bound
okay so just to kind of conclude
everything the upshot of all this i ran
a little slow
was that
um what we were going to get a hot to
this gave us an approximate solution you
can then solve a linear program to get
to turn an approximate one into an exact
one
um and the kind of main moral picture
from the talk was spar you want to find
sparse objects
and if you do l2 versus l1 versus l
infinity bounds there's a very good
reason why they cut off at one over root
n which is just that subspaces either
tend to or always do have vectors with
bad ratios of l one versus infinity
and so what we can do is replace that
with a ratio of other polynomial norms
and the ratio now that we're looking at
is the two versus four norm uh this is
an np hard problem to actually find but
often in many cases especially revolving
around sort of random instances or sort
of learning settings you can actually
certify the bound on the optimum even if
you can't um
actually always find it and then that
certificate enough is by itself enough
to round these stp solutions
okay so i think um i'm five minutes over
my five minutes overtime and so
maybe i will take questions offline and
thanks